so I want to give you a hypothetical
situation okay
Collier might back to when we're doing
like first principles and introducing
gradient functions in the lab in the
first place okay so because I gave you a
function okay and it has a wider set of
three and when actually they're about
okay now simple example right but
suppose I wanted to know gradient okay
now it's it's trivial I know but let's
just go through the process anyway
okay what's the gradient of this
straight straight line how do I work out
the gradient the definition of the
gradient is rising so in this case how
do I calculate rise well it's it's let's
take two points
okay the points already given you that's
why five 1303 so what I'm going to get
here is that's 13 ministry that's them
how far I've gone up and half hour of I
run across okay so I get 1005 society is
- okay now what could that tell me if I
wanted to draw the gradient function of
this it would be pretty simple right it
would lead to - it would just be this
straight line okay because it's a it's
got a constant rate no problems but what
I want you to imagine now is let's try
to turn this one's head in a specific
example okay now gradient being rise
over run okay in some of the questions
we've been looking at the applications
of differentiation we've thought of this
as like actual physical quantities
for instance okay gradient is another
way to say how fast is something moving
okay now think back to like what about
you seven or eight science what is the
definition of speed how does it relate
to rise over run its distance over time
okay now so far I've been thinking of
this in these terms so in this case
working on gradient
I'm divided by DX and that course one
isn't dividing by time if you like but
what I have in is this Riemann integral
business right it's not division by DX
but multiplication now what would that
mean well looking here rearranging this
equation right if I multiplied through
by DX what you'd get is let's see here
rise is gradient that means now that's a
bit abstract okay and that's why I
brought this speed just this time thing
ago because this makes sense to us when
you think about in terms of this what it
is I'm dy what does rice correspond over
here distance right well how do you work
out the distance you traveled if you
know how long you've traveled and have
ice-cream travel well distance that's
okay sir I've got some things I want to
something here okay I've got a a Y over
here and then we've got a grain of some
kind right so and DX okay now this is
this is helpful to me because it's not
exactly the same there's not rivers but
it looks like something like the process
we're doing okay so let me try and
reverse this right I'm coming from now
this kind of situation right so instead
of knowing rise and run and working out
gradient
I want to nourish speed and timing
worked out distance okay so what I've
got is when he was my arm
he was migrating function like my speed
function if you like and it was just
that F - do you wanna dance equals -
well if this is my speed right
that's my speed where's time on this
where's time well time is time is this
way isn't it
I should really write with my feet it's
my time axis so if I want speed times
time okay
and what I had before was knew five
seconds Prince's okay speed times time
here is just the area of a rectangle
mainly this one okay does that make
sense
now obviously the area of this rectangle
was 10 now what did that 10 signify in
the loss scenario we just had what we
looked at it in Reverse okay where did
that 10 come from that's 10 came from
this side right from the 3 and 13 okay
does that make sense
it's the 13 minus 3 that's where this 10
appeared when we thought about it in
Reverse okay
- I should really say 15 - 3 and this 5
is 5 months zero times to make sense
speedy was - yeah okay now he's the
important thing though 13 - cream that's
kind of like a shortcut way of what yeah
instead of working at Aragon if I know
the function that it came from the
function that I had to differentiate in
order to get to this right then I don't
need to work out no if I wanted to
account area if there's some we do it
being okay all I need to know is where I
start and where I end on that visual
function where I came from now rather
than saying original function where it
came from we have language for this it's
called the primitive function right so
if you can know what the primitive is
then all you need to do to work out this
read area if it's a weird area right
it's going to a primitive of this and
just take your start and end points
that's all you need okay now how do we
work permit if we usually say if fun if
this is right sorry
he is a way to write it if I'm trying to
work out area okay under this lowercase
F okay and if I know what the period is
if I know what capital F is okay all
that is is one point - the other isn't
it
where are stop where I end I see it so
while Rio is trying to work out right
his weiner calculations and I kind of
thing and put into this infinite
infinite if you interesting with small
rectangles okay was to say if you want
to work out what an area is out of all
of these rectangles then what you really
need to have known from the
places where the function came from okay
and then what you need to do is subtract
we need to do now we know that the
process that we would call this process
very deliberately anti-differentiation
okay because we're used to starting a
capital F and going the other way
okay but he called it integration
because he was trying to solve a
completely different problem okay does
this make sense work out an area it
turns out these are the same problem
working out area is the inverse of
working out Radian which is weird I
don't know if that makes sense to you
you're like I I want to know area I'll
just undo gradient that seems they don't
seem like opposites to me like left and
right like what other like square and
the square root okay but area grading
them like that okay sir all that to say
why have we been doing a differentiation
what was the point of it it's because
what we want area make sense